congrats to 90 day fiances alex and
lauren they're expecting baby number
three
how big of a family do you want at least
three
well that dream is becoming a reality
the couple breaking the happy news
exclusively to e.t with alex sharing
quote omg i am so excited and scared at
the same time three kids under the age
of three is no joke my dream of a soccer
team is slowly becoming a reality and
lauren adds quote this was quite a shock
to say the least and while we're
entering a whole new chapter i'm very
excited we aren't going to find out the
gender until the baby is born i'd be
lying if i said i wasn't terrified i am
but nothing we can't handle we can't
wait to meet baby b this fall
this is my biggest kid don't let anybody
fool you he's my biggest kid
easy just sat down with lauren in march
where she touched on her hubby talking
her into expanding their family
has he convinced you to make this happen
soon or what
he's very good at what he does he does
this jedi mind trick right so he'll say
lauren
you want to have a mommy makeover right
yes i do you want a mommy makeover oh
yes like a full oh hello hello goodbye
yeah
so that would have to be after the fact
though right well that's what he says
right you know
you are working out so hard to get your
body back to then get pregnant again
just think about you can have a mommy
makeover sooner than later
he's so right and i hate that he does
that but he knows how to get to me you
know how to get to him too though yeah
but he always gets what he wants
always
[Music]
you